frente al castillo de balmoral los hijos
de la reina isabel se acercaron a
saludar a los lugareños andrés and a
eduardo se tomaron su tiempo leyendo
decenas de sentidos mensajes de
condolencia dirigidos a la familia real
la gente ha llegado al lugar desde todo
el reino unido para rendir homenaje a su
reina cuyo cuerpo aún reside en el
palacio
queríamos venir a presentar nuestros
respetos a la reina para despedirnos y
para que los niños tuvieran un momento
único en su vida es importante que la
recuerden
es muy triste ella siempre estuvo ahí
para mí toda mi vida
als
es un momento triste y queríamos venir
con nuestros nietos para rendirle
homenaje ebro reflex el cortejo fúnebre
de la reina saldrá del castillo de
escocia la comitiva llegará a edimburgo
al palacio de holyroodhouse la
residencia oficial del monarca británico
en ese territorio el lunes se celebrará
una ceremonia religiosa en la catedral
de saint gilles con la presencia de la
familia real el público podrá pasar en
fila para presentar sus últimos respetos
el martes la princesa anna acompañará el
cuerpo de su majestad hasta el palacio
de buckingham en londres la reina
permanecerá en capilla ardiente durante
cuatro días en westminster hall donde se
espera que asistan cientos de miles de
personas el lunes 19 de septiembre se
celebrará el funeral de estado en la
abadía de westminster el cuerpo de la
reina isabel será velado en la capilla
de san jorge del castillo de windsor el
ataúd de su marido el príncipe felipe
fallecido el pasado año será exhumado de
la bóveda real y será colocado junto a
ella